-Our next guest
is a best-selling author
and National Book Award winner
His novel, "The Water Dancer,"
is available in paperback
November 17th,
and the adaptation of his book
"Between the World and Me,
airs November 21st
on HBO and HBO Max.
Please welcome back to the sho
Ta-Nehisi Coates.
How are you, Ta-Nehisi?
-Hey! How's it going?
Nice to be here, Seth.
-It's always great to see you.
For my money,
you've written some of the bes
journalistic pieces
on the presidency,
on the country,
over the last decade.
You obviously have laid ou
your differences of opinio
with Joe Biden over the years,
yet also made it very clea
that he's a better choice if the
other choice is Donald Trump
Based on that,
I'm assuming you were not
celebrating in the streets
on Saturday,
but how did you feel about
the people that were?
-I wasn't. I was not
celebrating in the streets
That's just not something
I would do.
That's not how
I interact with the world.
That actually is not even
any reflection on Joe Biden.
I understand
the people who were.
It's been a tough four years
I totally, totally get it.
I do worry that
maybe we do not know how dar
it's about to get, you know,
again, really, really quickly.
But at the same time,
people are human beings.
I understand it.
I get it.
You know, Trump was a different,
you know, magnitude, you know,
of corruption and a threat
to the state and to democracy.
So I understand it.
I understand it.
It wouldn't be what I would do
but I get it.
-I want to talk about the sort
of two different sides of this
that I think people
are weighing, which is, one --
And you've said
about Donald Trump,
you're not necessarily a racis
if you vote for him,
but his racism
is not disqualifying for you
if you vote for him.
-That's right.
-And he got more votes
than he did last time.
On the other hand,
you have Joe Biden,
you have Kamala Harris
got more votes than anyone
So, how do you sort of see
the two working in concert
-Um...Well, you know,
I-I don't know.
It's distressing that
Donald Trump got more votes.
I think we had just
a record level of participation,
so the sheer amount of Americans
that were involved
in the process was beyond
anything that we'd ever seen
I think that's a good thing.
You know?
I would prefer a world where
more people voted
and my side lost the argumen
to a world where the other sid
worked to suppress
the numbers of people who vote
and we lost because of that.
Democracy -- you know,
you don't win every battle
in a democracy, and that's fine,
so I was heartened by that
I know how to deal
with losing the argument.
You just go back.
You figure it out.
You try to make
the argument again.
So, you know, while on
some level it is depressing,
and there's all sorts of thing
I can say about the appeal
you know,
that Trump ultimately had
and what that says
about the country.
I think more people
participating is a good thing.
I'm not sure that, you know,
the party in power right now
currently believes that.
-I think it's safe to say
they don't believe that.
-It's pretty safe.
Pretty safe.
-Hey, I want to talk to you --
-I'm going out on a limb there
[ Both laugh ]
-I want to talk to you about
the fact that not just
"Between the World and Me"
is about to be a TV show,
but now "The Water Dancer"
is gonna be a film.
What is it like for you
to turn over your work
to people that will then adapt
it for a different medium?
-So, uh...difficult.
[ Laughs ]
Very difficult.
With "Between the World and Me,"
I had the great luxury
of turning it over to
a very, very old friend of mine,
Kamilah Forbes, who goes bac
to my days at Howard University.
So that was pretty easy,
and she did a staging
here in New York that I thought,
you know, went off pretty well
so I trust her implicitly.
She's also
my wife's best friend,
so that makes all of that
very, very easy...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-...to do.
You know,
as for "The Water Dancer,"
I'm gonna be the one
writing the screenplay
and doing the adaptation,
so that shows you
about how much I trust people...
[ Both laugh ]
...to adapt the work.
So, for good or for ill,
you know,
we'll find out how that goes
-You know, another thing you did
a lot of the ground work on,
and we've talked about
this before,
but you had this incredible ru
on the "Black Panther"
comic-book series.
This was before it was a film.
And you also mentioned knowing
people from your Howard days
You knew Chadwick Boseman
from your Howard days, as well
What was that
whole journey like?
-Uh...Well, you don't know
that you're on a journey,
and so it's only
with his regrettable passing
that, you know,
I've become wistful
and begun to think about it.
You know, I met Chad,
wildly enough,
when I was a student journalis
at the newspaper
and he was leading
a protest at the university.
And actually leading the protest
was Kamilah Forbes,
who is adapting
"Between the World and Me,
so it's the way that
these worlds come together
And I was a journalist
at that time,
so I was reporting on
what was a student takeover,
and Chad was one of the leaders,
if not the leader.
So I knew him as, you know
a student and a young man
of really strong principle
I also knew him as an artist
not just as an actor,
but as a writer,
as a director at that time
He is the last person
in the world
that I would have thought
would become who he became
not because of any lack
of talent, not because of any,
you know, lack of ability or
intellect or anything like that.
But Chad was so principled, man.
He wanted what he wanted,
and he wanted how he wanted it
And, you know,
that was gonna be it.
And so it's shocking to me t
watch what he ultimately became,
and yet when he was chosen
to be Black Panther,
I couldn't think of anybod
who would be better,
because even back
in our Howard days,
he had that same
sort of regal bearing
that he brought to T'Challa.
It wasn't a total reach
for Chad to do that.
And it's a huge,
huge loss to see him gone.
-You saw him, I guess,
it was probably at the premier
of "Black Panther"?
Is this the photo we have
of you guys together?
-Oh, you guys blew that up
I did, yes.
Yes, that's myself,
my wife, and Chad, yeah.
-That's fantastic.
And it really is.
What a journey to have bee
in college with somebody
and then sort of help --
I don't know --
rewrite the character
that made him so famous.
-Yeah. That was --
It was such a coincidence, too
It was, like, weird.
Like I, you know...
Like, from my perspective,
I, you know,
wanted to be a comic-book writer
when I was a kid,
but I never thought
it was actually gonna happen
And I know the strongest par
of Chad was, you know,
the writing and directing part
Here he becomes
this huge leading man.
You know, the night
that picture was taken,
it was at the premiere,
and I saw him, you know,
across the room.
And he, you know, had this -
He never --
He never changed.
The celebrity part of him
actually never changed
who he was.
And he looked...
like he did not enjoy
being in a giant party,
surrounded by a bunch of peopl
he didn't know.
And my thinking was, you know,
having had about .001%
of a taste of that,
I'm not even gonna go over
and talk to Chad.
I'll see Chad when I see him
My wife was so excited,
went over and talked to him,
and he came over
and wanted to take this pictur
and talk and everything.
You know, he was always just s
good about that sort of thing.
I obviously didn't know
at the time that he was sick
-That part of it is so tragi
and so retroactively --
retrospectively, I should say,
so impressive
what he was going through.
-Yeah, no, he carried it.
You know, and whatever pai
that he was going through,
which I assume
to be quite considerable,
he carried it.
-Well, thank you
for sharing those stories
about Chad,
and thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a pleasur
to talk to you, Ta-Nehisi.
-Thanks so much, Seth.
Thanks for having me.